oh I would argue that all of them should
be legal overarching ly for the same
reason that the state really has very
little interest controlling what people
do in their own private lives in their
own bedrooms unless it directly it
negatively affects other people in a
tangible way and I'm not convinced with
any of those particular items whether
it's bestiality polygamy incest do have
that effect on consenting adults or
between human beings and animals where
consent really is not a meaningful
question I think you have to ant assess
each of these phenomena in its own terms
though and I've written fairly
extensively on each I think the concerns
about polygamy are structural while it
is entirely not my concern that people
want to have three or four wives or 30
or 40 husbands and they tell some
cultures they do and cultures survive
quite well my one concern would be if
for example the person who decides
they're gonna have 40 wives and we're
like Social Security to pay benefits to
all of them after their demise and we
have to set up a system to balance the
rights of people to marry who would have
many people they choose with one that
controls funding of this in a way that
the rest of society can function in the
same manner while I think the allottee
per se should be legal I think there may
be forms of bestiality that transcends
into animal cruelty and there the
government might want to step in I think
the important distinction to make
is it not inherently clear that sex
between animals and humans is
unpleasurable for the animals and in
fact there are documented cases were
clearly the opposite there is a man who
off the coast of England masturbates
with dolphins not something I would
particularly choose to do but he seems
to find it fulfilling and we know that
dolphins find it fulfilling because they
keep coming back for more I think you're
hard-pressed to argue this is
fundamentally on had to go on people
talking about animals not being able to
consent your dog can't consent when you
play frisbee with it either
there's nobody evaluates the question of
Metra prostitution
we often hear is the objection is that
this leads to Vice leads to crime with
the undermining of a social fabric of
the community in countries that have
legalized or decriminalized prostitution
Amsterdam comes to mind
Sweden comes to mind crime rates have
actually gone down the prostitutes
rather than being victims can leave
stable middle-class lodging they're
protected
so in some ways it's a suspicious
argument the objections to all of these
phenomena are really not what people say
they are people say they're concerned
about the welfare of these individuals
what they're really interested in doing
is imposing their own social values
where their own religious values and
other people and that's what really
concerns me